Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow episode 7 Vigilante
video just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet.
It was the twist of all twists at the end
so just to start things off I will say that
the Vigilante character is not the Prometheus
character, it's not the same person underneath
the mask for those that are wondering because
some of you might know who Vigilante is from
the comics we saw him in this episode but
just for the people that don't read comics.
I don't want to spoil that upfront but if
you're not sure rewatch the last couple of
episodes I think they've done a good job teasing
a certain character reveal for Vigilante without
beating you in the face with that so let's
do top 10 WTF there was a big twist at the
end which is actually really cool so much
stuff going on and we know about the Arrow
100th episode so talk about that at the end
of the video to because is a whole bunch of
stuff happening around that in two weeks.
So number 10 meet Vigilante the newest Vigilante
dropping bodies in Star city in there was
an impressive body count in this episode but
you have to remember that he's going people
about this can be a ton of bodies they've
actually been about six different versions
of the character in the comics.
They actually Flashed a picture of original
art by George Perez for his version of the
Vigilante character who if you know who that
is in the comics then you know who he is on
the TV show there sticking pretty close to
his origin in they kind of teased that in
this episode, so number nine you haven't been
pushed over the edge like Vigilante tells
Oliver you may have lost people you haven't
reached the point that ivories Vigilante's
family was gunned down punisher Stossel his
punisher type origin story where he goes to
really this upstanding member of the community
to being a Vigilante the just guns down criminals
indiscriminately which kind of dovetails with
you know number eight the dark versus light
paths Oliver has this big existential crisis
in the episode were he's like maybe nothing
we been doing is working.
I don't understand like should we just start
dropping bodies again was the deal, but what
would normally be Felicity scene were she's
like hey you know do things the right way
is actually the Susan Williams character.
It tells him to chill out just a little bit
and just stay the course like you're doing
it the right wages do not turn to the dark
side Anakin Skywalker, so number 7 also happening
in the Flashbacks to almost the exact same
story Kovar gives him the same version of
that speech worries like good evil, it's all
relative the brought but made a deal with
me to get a portion of my profits.
That's the only reason they let you in the
organization.
So Flashback Oliver just like had his whole
world flipped upside down so now it seems
like he's never going to get revenge but obviously
they just want things seem really terrible,
so that he is to climb out of another whole
or climb off of another island so to speak,
but the real big twist.
You know number six is the Taiana his mother
like the person who he's trying to kill Kovar
for is working for Kovar what a sweet woman
you probably know her daughter Taiana and
Flashback Oliver just like craps his pants
like oh my God.
So the whole point of the Flashbacks like
all the scenes is just to make Kovar seen
invincible and untouchable like this insurmountable
goal.
So it just could be that much more satisfying
when Oliver takes him down if he is able to
taken down by the end of the season so I know
it's a long ways off.
I'm not expecting it but it would be pretty
bad ass.
If Prometheus turned out to be Kovar or someone
connected to Kovar you do get the sense that
he has a larger role to play because he's
such a big figure in the Flashbacks.
So it would seem weird if Flashback Oliver
is able to defeat him and then we never hear
from him or his organization again usually
the Flashbacks sink up with modern-day a little
bit to just expect that Kovar plot to get
teased out the same way the tease out Prometheus
and now the Vigilante character speaking of
Prometheus number five Quentyn comes clean
to Thea he knows he's been blacking out but
he has no idea what's going on in is convinced
someone is trying to pin the Prometheus murders
on him.
I think that whole speech was just to throw
water on the idea the Quentyn is being mind
control when he's blacked out like he's not
a secret ninja without knowing about it.
So there's some of the character whose Prometheus
they are just messing with Quentyn because
as Oliver finds out number four Prometheus
knows who he is.
Meaning that he knows about team Arrow knowing
that Quentyn is connected to it all.
So number three team Arrow versus Vigilante
round one there was that awesome trick shot
where he bull's-eye Artemis's Arrow is able
to get away pretty easily till round to where
he actually gets the drop on team Arrow as
they're trying to lay a trap for him to like
the whole point here like the fact that he
gets away without Oliver being able to unmask
them just let you know that it's going to
be a much bigger plot line like that I just
could unmask them right away and that'll be
the end of it and if you know who he is on
the show then you can start to guess but maybe
he'll find out Oliver secret before Oliver
learns his secret in the lead to some really
fun times so does go ahead and say it's okay
to talk about who he really is on the TV show
if you've read the comics or if you know that
twist but just use a spoiler tag in the comments
when you're talking about it when I'm expecting
is is that his storyline will kind of collide
with Prometheus the storyline relatively quickly
like before the midseason finale where will
probably get a big reveal about Vigilante's
character and Prometheus's character at the
same time.
But they are two different people, so number
one WTF though.
This is really fun.
I really like this twist Artemis is working
with Prometheus.
So it's a very sports mastery twist for those
you didn't watch young justice Artemis on
that show had a different origin story from
Artemis on Arrow so young justice Artemis
is actually the daughter of two villains one
of them is sports master.
So her whole arc on that TV show was about
not following in her parents footsteps even
though you come from evil that doesn't mean
that you have to be evil.
So on Arrow you can guess that that might
have something to do with Artemis as well.
You can see that she is so upset about Oliver
not being able to help her parents that that's
probably what drove her to start working with
Prometheus so I don't think that Prometheus
is her father I think that is just someone
who has be against team Arrow in Oliver.
Specifically, so the enemy of my enemy is
my friend.
Thus Artemis and Prometheus are friends temporarily
let me know what you guys thought of the episode.
I'd I thought move pretty well so little bit
about that, though the Arrow hundred episode.
This is separately from Laurel coming back
in the second half of the season don't really
know how that's can happen.
But they did explain a lot about the hundred
episode, most of which will take place in
a dream sequence where Oliver didn't get on
the Queen's Gambit so like he is a completely
different life they kind of imply that there
is no green Arrow so use have fun seeing what
Star City is like what those characters are
like had they gone down a different path.
So like Laurel is still alive.
It looks like she and Oliver are getting ready
to get married, then Oliver starts to notice
little things are off.
So he can we comes to the realization that
he's in an artificial reality that has something
to do with the Dominators because of course
it happens during the third night of the four
night crossover so we don't know how long
were going to spend in that dream sequence
during the Arrow episode, but I'm guessing
at least like half of the episode is going
to be this Arrow.
What if they actually did the same thing on
Batman the animated series where Batman enters
hypnosis and he experiences this reality where
his parents were not gun down in crime aley
so everything's weird he's not the Batman
until he slowly starts to realize that what
he's experiencing is not real.
So that's probably the way it can go down
with Oliver but that episode isn't dropping
for another two weeks.
So next week Arrow is on break but I think
the other shows are still happening of the
Flash for sure has a new episode next week
so I think Arrow is the only one that's on
break.
So just post updates on the schedule as I
post new DC videos but there is new legends
tomorrow night.
Jonah Hex is coming back and there's a big
change in the legend schedule and the second
half of the season so what they're doing is
is when everything comes back in the spring
legends is going to aired after the Flash
at 9 PM on Tuesday night so it's gonna be
Supergirl on Mondays and the Flash and legends
one right after the other and then Arrow on
Wednesdays.
So there will be no DC TV shows on Thursdays
anymore it'll be Monday Tuesday Wednesday
which makes Tuesday really interesting because
I try to do videos for agents of shield every
once in a while.
So we'll figure the schedule out but it's
not going to happen for a while but just a
reminder new round of the DC giveaway going
on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card so I'll announce the
winner when I post my legends video tomorrow
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the 4 night
crossover and you can click here for the Flash
Killer Frost trailer for next week's Flash
episode thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight!